olá pessoal inicialmente eu gostaria de
externar o grande é grande honra grande
orgulho de estar participando de um de
um evento tão grande tão bacana como
esse de alcance tão longo especialmente
pra falar acerca do que basicamente é
meu dia a dia é o quanto as minhas
maiores paixões no que diz respeito ao
conhecimento é gasto tempo estudando um
gasto um tempo trabalhando no bolso
gasto é meu ganha-pão de verdade é como
vocês viram eu sou médico dermatologista
ansioso o lojista ii enquanto que boa
parte dos profissionais que andou se
especializando a dermatologia tem
gostado muito da parte stent que
realmente uma parte muito apaixonante
tem uma procura muito grande né
é eu acabei indo no caminho contrário e
eu gosto o do tema isi
a hanseníase é uma doença que todos já
ouviram falar
eu aposto que mesmo quem é diária
completamente distante a medicina é um
pouco a respeito do microfone tá tá bom
e é que eu tenho que eu vim falar um
pouquinho respeito pra vocês
essa essa doença que é histórica
você já ouviu falar que tem até um peso
social para os indivíduos que a detêm
tem sido um grande desafio ela já foi
ela foi descrita há muitos séculos antes
da antes de cristo
na época de cristo ea gente encontra em
relatos bíblicos
inúmeros casos é a desde uma praga até
uma sua cura era algo como uma salvação
coisa do tipo
e desde aquela época até hoje essa
doença continua se transmitindo de
pessoa para pessoa é uma doença que cujo
cuja bactéria não acomete outros outros
seres apenas um ser humano sendo que nós
somos o terceiro reservatório dessa
doença e ela ainda existe até hoje
incrivelmente e nada mais é do que uma
bactéria essa bactéria é chamada
mycobacterium leprae ela ela tem uma
estrutura na louca altério tuberculoses
que é o agente da tuberculose
então é ter uma um ecologista estrutural
grande entre a micobacterium leprae do
barco lose o que eu vim falar a respeito
da hanseníase primeiro
pessoal esse nome hanseníase é o nome
quase que é utilizado apenas no brasil
porque é no mundo inteiro aquele termo
lepra que todo mundo conhece todo mundo
já ouviu falar encontrado em livros de
literatura religiosa etc
é é ainda usa o termo lepra mundo
inteiro elétrons ea tradução am seja um
termo nosso é não vou é criticar ou
defender mas o nosso país carrega sim um
algodão politicamente correto que se eu
falar que ele é leproso o senhor fala
que ele a idéia é tico eu estou sendo
preconceituoso então ele tem hanseníase
e outro uma pessoa que convive com o hiv
ou aids
então a gente tem toda uma nomenclatura
para de forma alguma ofender
esse tipo de coisa é é causado por essa
bactéria que já comentei com vocês e é
uma grande preocupação tanto do
ministério da saúde do brasil quanto da
organização mundial de saúde
a organização mundial de saúde ela
determina que um país é considerado
livre da epidemia de hanseníase se nós
temos menos de um caso para cada 10 mil
habitantes
atualmente o brasil tem 1,65 casos para
cada 10 mil habitantes
a gente ainda não atingiu o alvo e muito
pelo contrário somos atualmente o
segundo país com maior número de casos a
gente perde apenas para a índia
aqui na região sul nós temos em torno de
0,4 casos para cada 10 mil habitantes
isso é bom para a gente nós já atingimos
a meta porém quase todos os casos da
região sul estão no paraná
então a nossa preocupação devemos
permanecer em alerta
a região sudeste tem em torno de 06 a 07
casos para cada 10 mil habitantes e as
outras regiões chegam a ter índices de
até 45 casos para cada 10 mil habitantes
e é por isso que existe uma dificuldade
maior para o nosso controle
temos muito o que fazer a respeito dessa
patologia
se a gente abrir o livro do ministério
da saúde
na primeira página que vai está escrito
lá como fazer o diagnóstico de
hanseníase quem têm hanseníase número 1
pessoa com mancha dormente ponto que não
olha que simples e se o primeiro pilar
para fazer o diagnóstico e um apenas
basta se consentem mancha e não senti
teoricamente têm hanseníase é claro que
ele necessita passar por uma avaliação
especializada mas teoricamente o
ministério da saúde já determina isso
a segunda forma é através de um exame
denominado baciloscopia que que é isso a
baciloscopia seria a pesquisa do agente
da bactéria que tem características
muito clássicas de coloração e
é temos uma certa habilidade na sua
detecção quando for coletada a linfa a
linfa que é um dos líquidos orgânicos
que nós detemos e que pode ser coletado
em logo de orelha em cotovelo e de
manchas
após fazer uma ordenha naquela mancha a
gente consegue retirar limpa vai pro
laboratório o laboratório avaliando vai
dizer esse paciente tem baciloscopia
positiva esse paciente tem baciloscopia
negativa quem tem baciloscopia positiva
nossa tá correndo na limpa o bicho amigo
micobactéria é óbvio que ele tenha
doença
essa é a segunda forma de fazer o
diagnóstico ea terceira forma de fazer o
diagnóstico é achado de nervo expressado
nervo mais grosso do que o habitual
nós temos determinados troncos nervosos
que com alguma habilidade
depois de aprender a examinar direitinho
com pessoa habilitada
nós conseguimos até com alguma
facilidade pau para alguns nervos à
hanseníase o mycobacterium leprae é
absolutamente apaixonado por um nervo
chamado nervo ulnar e esse nervo na ele
percorre o território no braço em que
ele passa próximo mas proeminência
sócias que facilitam a sua detecção
então se o dermatologista ou o clínico
ou o profissional habilitado palma
região do trajeto desse nervo
e esse nervo está dispensado
não existe outra doença que espécie é
negro nessa vida
apenas a hanseníase terceira forma de
fazer o diagnóstico é com uma das 31 é
você preenchendo um desses três
critérios
você já pode começar o tratamento eu
poderia falar um pouquinho sobre como se
manifesta à hanseníase
ela não é apenas uma doença de manchas
dormentes se ela fosse isso até que
estava bom
só que o problema é que ela não é apenas
uma doença de pele
apesar dos e dermatologista eu tenho que
estar muito atento para a qual
acometimento dos nervos que eu acabei de
comentar e agora começa a aproximar o
conhecimento científico com o
conhecimento que quem não é da área já
ouviu falar de algumas deformidades
algumas sequelas paciente queimou o
braço que em uma perna senti cheiro de
queimado e não sabe o que está
acontecendo como assim que está
acontecendo
os nossos nervos eles são envoltos por
uma proteína chamada mielina
e esse agente essa bactéria ela é tem
tropismo ela gosta de viver nessa bainha
de mielina nessa mielina que recobre os
nervos
ao fazer isso o nosso próprio organismo
ataca essa bactéria reconhece essa
bactéria como um agente estranho e
atacando a bactéria ataca o nervo junto
e esse é o grande problema da hanseníase
os acometimentos nervosos se você trata
em tempo eficaz
em tempo é precoce você consegue evitar
que fiquem sequelas para esse paciente
só que muitas vezes o paciente chega pra
mim já total
somente sequelado pela doença e aí eu já
não tenho muito o que fazer que é de
seis meses a um ano ele vai começar a
ficar com as sequelas relacionadas ao
acometimento desse nervo a mão do
paciente começa a ficar com esse aspecto
esse aspecto nós denominamos garra mas
como a garra pega só o lado da mão
enervado pelo nervo mar
nós chamamos de garra unar a bactéria é
organizada então sempre tem a mesma
ordem
depois desse nervo ela começa a cometer
um nervo mediano que ele passa aqui
pertinho do punho se o paciente tem o
acometimento do mediano depois do nar
ele já fica com a garra completa só é
inadmissível um paciente chegar pra mim
com garra completa
mas chega com freqüência como eu vou
corrigir isso pessoal já saiu da minha
alçada
eu consigo matar bactérias agora fazer
uma deformidade dessa voltar ao normal
eu vou precisar de ortopedista às vezes
com cirurgia o fisioterapia com com
aparatos outros fisioterápico
fisioterápicos que vão auxiliar nessa
nessa melhora clínica depois de pegar o
nervo mediano ele pode por fim pegar um
nervo radial que passa aqui na altura do
músculo tríceps e é responsável pela dor
se flexão do punho que o indivíduo vai
apresentar mão caída chega paciente
assim ainda hoje por incrível que pareça
chega e eu vou fazer um vovô fazer um
adendo aqui pra vocês pessoal
a hanseníase um dos grandes problemas
dela é que você é
ao estar em contato com indivíduo doente
você pode
é pegar a doença por vias respiratórias
só que essa doença ela se manifesta em
média de três a seis anos depois ela tem
um período pra começar as suas
manifestações muito tardio isso
dificulta muito para a gente porque até
começar às manifestações
ela está transmitindo bacilo pra todo
mundo e em torno de 10% da população é
suscetível a esse bacilo esse é um dos
grandes problemas da doença
imagina você sentado do lado de uma
pessoa com gripe a pessoa espirra e você
pega a gripe três anos depois é bem
estranho isso mas essa bactéria desse
jeito porque elas se reproduzem
lentamente ela tem mecanismos um pouco
diferentes
ela é diferente gente ela existe desde
épocas remotas épo e por essa essa forma
um pouco peculiar dela ter o seu o seu o
seu desenvolvimento que ela vem até hoje
dando surra na gente ea gente não chega
no alvo que a oms coloca pra gente né
nas pernas as pernas também podem ser
acometidas pela hanseníase em dois
nervos principais que são o fibular
comum o que não é comum passa aqui na
perna atrás o que a gente chama de
cabeça da fíbula
pra quem não tem tanta noção de anatomia
a é um ossinho num acidente ósseo que
tem aqui esse nervo é responsável para a
gente fazer esse movimento mas é dor se
flexão do pé
se o paciente tiver o acometimento desse
nervo quando ele anda ele arrasta o pé
a gente chama isso de marcha scar vant
isso dificulta marcha do paciente e é
mais uma sequela com que o paciente com
hanseníase pode ficar e mais uma que eu
comentava as centenas outras que o
paciente pode apresentar é o
acometimento dos nervos chamado tibial
posterior que ele é responsável por
inteiro
a a planta do pé imaginem vocês não
sentindo mas a planta do pé
a gente nem consegue imaginar isso é um
é algo complicado para quem não tem
chega paciente pra mim e queixa
doutor eu não tenho nada mandaram eu vim
aqui porque eu perco chinelo como assim
perde o chinelo
ele perdeu a sensibilidade dos pés e
perdendo a sensibilidade dos pés
ele não percebe nenhum chinês saiu do pé
ele chega em casa com o pé cortado é
sangrando
sem o chinelo e não sabe nem o que está
acontecendo com esses indivíduos têm
todo um cuidado mais especial como os
pés que nós devemos estar sempre
orientando pessoal e que acontece a
gente pisa no uma pedrinha ou num caco
de vidro ou em coisa do tipo a gente
percebe precocemente rápido às vezes até
no reflexo ea gente já tira esse
indivíduo sente gira e o ferimento
progride e amanhã ele pisa de novo e de
novo e de novo começa a ficar começou a
se formar um ser as graves que vão
deslizando músculo vão lesando o osso
vão destruindo pé vai destruindo a mão
porque a mão a gente não põe no chão mas
ela queima ele queima no forno ele
queima trabalhando ele queima na mão
tudo que é lugar e assim o paciente vai
desenvolvendo sequelas tão graves quanto
essas que eu comentei é se eu pudesse
deixar uma mensagem final sobre essa
doença que eu digo só eu atendo
semanalmente 30 pacientes ainda com
hanseníase um seqüelados tinha certeza
que vocês iam ficar com esse olhar
estupefato quanto quando eu falar assim
o problema não está resolvido estamos na
região do brasil com
menor incidência eu ainda vejo 30 casos
por semana têm de hoje cedo eu marco 15
enquanto que o marco 15
os outros dois matou lojistas mas com 15
vão 10 alguns faltam eu marco 15 ou 16
porque hanseníase não falta e são
preocupados eles são eles fazem tudo
direitinho conforme a gente manda a
doença não está controlada é ela tem uma
meia-vida demorada o doente vai ter
doença muito tempo depois quem teve
contato vai ter que no médio prazo e se
pegou com pato int geralmente contato
dentro de casa mas ele vai ter que ficar
cinco anos uma vez por ano indo no
médico porque pode-se anos depois que
vai desenvolver a doença é essa doença
deixa sequelas
quando nós estamos com sequelas o
tratamento fica extremamente complicado
e vocês perceberam que o diagnóstico em
si não é difícil
mancha dormente baciloscopia da linfa
positiva que tanto médicos quanto
funcionários da área da saúde podem
estar pedindo e nervos dispensados que
esse sim requer um preparo um pouquinho
maior para o exame clínico e para a
detecção desses pacientes
gostaria de agradecer novamente a honra
de estar participando e eu tive alguns
pequenos problemas com o microfone mas
conseguimos dar segmento e espero que eu
tenha acrescentado alguma coisa esta
noite na vida de vocês
obrigado
[Aplausos]